do you know why I saw a guitar why I'm
about to call out my mum here so because
it wasn't actually my decision to start
guitar or I didn't have like a real like
I don't think I had interest in it but
my mum was like I'm signing you up to
guitar lessons I'm like okay why and
she's like you'll get girls
did you really yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
she was like girls like it when guys
play guitar I'm signing up films
I thought it was gonna be like a status
symbol thing because often it's seen as
a status symbol to make your kid as
talented in an instrument right yeah
yeah play the thing boy come on now play
the piano entertain my guess I think
it's more like a piano or like a violin
or like it's like classy my mom just
like tried to get like tried to like
Risk me up she was like this this will
be useful in life one day and then I
just started playing guitar and I I
think I was like as a kid I just like I
was the type of kid that just did things
because people told me to do it I didn't
really use a sheep
and I just continued doing guitar
lessons and then like accidentally
started a band just because I kept doing
guitar lessons
so it's so uh so basically the whole
reason why nine and a half pounds exists
is because of your mom yeah yeah yeah
let's go yeah I I never did any
instruments I actually did try to learn
drums but I just realized I just didn't
understand Rhythm like you said he was
trying to teach me it and I was like it
just doesn't make sense to me what do
you mean
just like I I he would try and teach me
like basic [__] I'm like I just don't
get it like I would I would be able to
replicate it yeah yeah but it would be
because I like had to translate it in my
head into like uh like like ones and
twos or like hitting numbers yeah like I
had a like a counting system like a
robot essentially like I I can't
recognize the Rhythm as like a a thing I
just I can't listen to it I can't
replicate it right so I gave up on that
pretty quickly
um and then I just did Sports a lot of
sports but only I only really like the
sports where it was like I hated team
sports because I hated having to be in a
team because the League of Legends yeah
exactly I hated having to rely on other
people all right which sounds so [__]
anime I don't need other people but I
genuinely like hated Sports where I had
to like I was part of a team because I I
wasn't very good no I'm totally the same
that's why I started tennis yeah well so
I didn't like that's a 1v1 bro yeah yeah
tennis but then I got into squash known
as racquetball everybody
squash as it's called in the UK
racquetball
um in the US or as I like to call it
privileged tennis it's normally like
yeah it's what's weird is I I guess like
when I left UK I realized how bizarre
this is like almost every
every Sports Center in Wales at least
I'm not sure about England
um they would have a squash call really
every single Sports Center they'd have a
tennis court they'd have uh is it big in
Wales uh it's pretty big in the UK I
guess it must be yeah it's pretty big
and they'd have like those there's the
like the giant concrete walls with the
glass front so yeah yeah and like every
a lot of people played it but then I
realized when watching American like TV
that it was only played by like super
rich businessmen when they wanted to
like talk yeah and it was like oh I used
to play that in school a lot it was golf
or squash yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so I played that I played uh I was on I
I guess by default I I played for Wales
for a little bit because there was there
wasn't many of us it was like number
like 19 or something number eight and
Wales no it's terrible uh it wasn't very
out of 19 places yeah
like the rankings uh and uh yeah it was
fun I like that and because I liked the
fact that I could just Sprint and hit a
ball really hard yeah because tennis was
so much about like technique and being
elegant
yeah and I I my brother did it as well
so I and it was kind of interesting
because we were like the Opposites I was
always looking to like smash it as hard
as I could yeah like an ogre like and I
was very fat like because I was I was I
was very good at sprinting so I was very
good at sprinting and smacking really
hard whereas my brother was really good
at technique right being like smiling
about it uh well we never played
together because he was in an older
bracket but yeah so I just I was just a
neanderthal uh right I was like hit it
everything I wanted to do I wanted to
just rely on like raw uh ability I never
wanted to study I never cared about get
like learning to get better I was like I
just want to be good at something you're
right just do it yeah over and over
again it's it's always weird to see to
like talk to people and just see how
many like weird hobbies and phases they
went through as a kid because like yeah
I remember when I was in like middle
school or high school or something I was
like on my like teams basketball team oh
my God
I mean the only reason I joined was
because uh we had PE and the coach was
like you should join the basketball team
and I'm like why and she's like you're
tall and I'm like okay now I only joined
because it was I read slam dunk and I
was like I want to [__] play this
game of course it was Joey I wasn't I
was the shortest dude in my team I'm
just like no no don't worry I can be
like meatly I'm I can be a short sprinty
fast guy in the team and I'll be good I
did that for like a few months and then
I was just like this is too hard yeah
were you were you any good at it I was
decent at it but I think it's because
like because I'd grown up doing a lot of
like Ball Sports like soccer and like
tennis and like just a whole variety of
them and like I did a bit of like
baseball and cricket and stuff like that
as well but nothing yeah too seriously I
think I was just amazing I did a bit of
baseball what the [__] yeah when I'd
come to Japan uh like I would have like
some friends who like play a bit of
baseball I've never played baseball I
think sometimes it's fine when I
explained to America's like no no we we
do not know anything about baseball we
don't under we don't know it it's we
don't have it no dude baseball would be
the perfect sport for you because
because if you're a batter you just have
to think to yourself I need to hit this
ball as hard as I [__] can yeah and
as a Fielder you just have to think I
need to grab the ball and throw it back
as hard as I [__] can there's no like
there's like little bits of finesse in
it but it's not like squash or like
tennis where you have to like think
about yourself
techniques to it there is technique but
not as much as like squash I don't know
yeah I don't know I don't know if this
is going to get my passport revoked
um I think like baseball is funner than
Cricket to play at least because I had
like one baseball uh we're in in peace I
know strong things about cricket by the
way I have no strong feelings okay okay
because okay so we had like you know in
PE uh in high school and everything we
had like you know Indian viewership
drops
hello fellow Americans uh but yeah we
had like one baseball lesson uh in in
rpe class because I guess there was like
one of our gym uh gym teachers was just
like really really [__] into baseball
and I'm like I've I despised every
Cricket lesson I ever had I was just
like maybe I just hate the act of
hitting a ball that's thrown at me on a
stick and then I've realized that when I
played baseball for some reason it was
just so much more satisfying when you
just get the strike in like way more
than it was for Cricket for me I don't
know why I just I something about the
way baseball I think it's because
swinging a bat like this yeah think it's
just more natural yeah than swinging
about like this yeah yeah you know like
holding something like this when
something is coming you've got to wear
all that stuff as well yeah yeah because
otherwise you're gonna have severe
injuries well I mean in baseball if the
pitcher is [__] you're gonna get you
know you're gonna get a fastball at you
right it's still dangerous yeah yeah
both I think I think uh the ball for
Cricket is obviously like a little bit
harder oh that thing is a rock oh yeah
Cricket gets [__] yeah I hated that
the amount of times that ball has just
like smacked right into my shin and left
the biggest bruise on me while playing
Cricket oh my God yeah that shit's
painful yeah so yeah I don't know I've
always found baseball more fun but like
there were so many sports that I wanted
to get into when I was younger but I
just also didn't have like uh I really
wanted I really enjoyed hockey hockey
actually a normal hockey just normal
hockey ice hockey because in America if
you say hockey it means that's hockey no
yeah just field hockey I guess yeah yeah
I've really really [__] enjoyed
hockey uh but in England at least I was
more seen as like you know that's that's
like what the girls do you know it's
like the girls did the girls did hockey
and netball and the guys played like
basketball and football you know yeah
and I I was like [__] but I I really
actually really [__] enjoy it but uh
we don't have it we didn't have a team
in our school but I really wanted to
play it more
um and uh yeah that's I've really
enjoyed that was there a sport you
always wanted to do but I never got the
chance to
oh even if it's like just for like one
time just to see if you'll like even
like it or just interested in trying it
the sports where I'm like how the [__]
did you get it how do you get into that
like the the one where what's the uh
like how do you if the one where they
ski and shoot things like I'm like how
the [__] do you even get into what what
you know the in the Winter Olympics when
they they do like the really long
distance like ski walking yeah yeah just
skiing but they're like oh growing up
here a lot of them yeah and they stop
and pull a gun out and start shooting
targets I've never seen that you've seen
this I've never seen that okay what's it
called
where I feel like I'd Crush at and I'm
like dude I feel like as a kid if you
let me do the what's it called uh clay
pigeon shooting yeah I feel like I'd pop
off because I've got the dog in there
because I feel like I would but I'm like
oh that's only for people from a very
wealthy background yeah you had Royals
close to a connection to some kind of
and you say like oh a lot of these
sports are kind of interesting you just
never get to try yeah you either don't
live in a place where it's done or you
just don't have the financial means to
do it like another one like that is like
skiing or something yeah that's that's
something that just requires being a bit
more wealthy yeah did you find a guy
no no no no no military Patrol yeah I
was going to say what kind of describe
sounded like a Call of Duty Mission yeah
right no no
it's a rifle I'm pretty sure that's a
scene from James Bond right you know
it's like a mission impossible yeah
and then these skis off into the
helicopter and Tom Cruise slaloming down
and then shooting a [__] RPG at a
helicopter
is a winter sport that combines
cross-country skiing and rifle shooting
it is treated as a race with contestants
skiing through a cross-country Trail
whose distance is divided into shooting
rounds so like how well you do on the
shooting gives you like time penalties
or or it's really cool but a man is is
it like one of those Sports I'm like how
the [__] do you even get into this
because you you you're cross-country
skiing but a lot of it is like the the
skiing where you're like kind of having
to do the like running things on it's
pretty [__] hard work and then on top
of that you gotta whip out a rifle shoot
it it's ridiculous I'm like who who came
up with this bro that's badass that is
badass it is dude I mean that's like
average I guess if you're just from
Finland that's just your childhood but
for like other countries I'm like who
the [__] who the [__] from like Morocco
learned to do this how do they literally
represent this how did this happen it's
like uh that's just like Cool Runnings
you know yeah yeah it's just a plot of
Cool Runnings well yeah I guess it's
like yeah it's like you're like how the
[__] was I was supposed to get into the
sport that looks cool like I'd love to
try and do pop sledding how the [__] do
I get into that yeah who do I go to am I
too old can I try now like what do I do
one one hobby that I kind of like am
interested in getting back into uh
because this is just like
I think everyone has like one Wild Card
that'd be a great hobby to have so am I
in my hearing hobby
uh I remember I went through a brief
period where I did like ballroom and
Latin America dancing oh and I was
actually really that would get [__]
fun that would raise people up that
would raise people send you the wrong
thing male dancers get so much holy [__]
so much yeah I mean I did it because a
mate kind of like dragged me to do it
yeah this is like this is like in
University phase uh he dragged me to
dirt because uh he uh wanted to meet
girls so he dragged me to bore him on
Latin America because he needed like he
needed the guy to go with him and I
ended up just really [__] enjoying it
and just doing it for two years because
it's actually really fun do you know
what's a male like uh like an activity
that you do as a male that gets you the
ultimate res what [__] ballet
that [__] will get you ultimate res
every time like it sounds like a budget
like Alpha conversation yeah it is it is
welcome to the diet Alpha podcast hello
today I'm going to convince you why
doing ballet will get you ultimate risk
hello it is I Andrew cake uh we're gonna
talk about the alternate the ultimate
Alpha uh ballet ballet ballet's where
it's at yeah I mean uh yeah I mean I
think now uh I want to get back into it
because I think it'd just be a really
fun thing to do with Sydney unromantic
plus there is like I I will swear to God
there is nothing that makes you feel
like more powerful as a man than just
dancing the tango with a girl man I'm
jealous man because I have like absolute
zero coordination when it comes to
dancing I cannot I I I have as well to
be fair to to say this I sucked at it I
I was that one guy that just sucked
today because I suck at dancing but it
just was so fun and that one time you
get the steps on and it's it's like you
know dancing like something like salsa
or Tango where you kind of like you as
that you have to like lead the girl so
what so like they have to like follow
your lead and there's just something so
[__] powerful about that feeling of
just being like okay for this one song
you have to follow everything I say and
everything I do not only that but that
comes in clutch at the retirement home
as well dog like if you're that one old
dude that could like break their hips
doing the salsa bro all the grannies
just feel like that man's still got the
rest after all these years yeah it is
weird to like a lot of girls I know
actually did ballet when they were
younger then it's funny you bring up
ballet because Sydney did that I don't
know like maybe maybe it's a [__]
Midwestern country girl thing but every
uh every girl is what piano is to Asian
parents oh yeah it's ballet it's a white
parents yeah I'm just speculating
it's hard to get analogy ballet is just
piano for white parents man it's like a
hobby that I 99 of kids will drop and
the one percent will keep doing it yeah
and the one percent that holds on to it
become like savants